[Musique]
bonjour je suis Mélissa sebir la
fondatrice de la mode de Mélissa et on
se retrouve aujourd'hui pour parler mode
je vais vous donner quelques conseils
pour avoir une penderie indémodable
[Musique]
parce que c'est important d'avoir un
dressing de plus en plus éthique je me
suis dit qu'il serait bien intéressant
de vous partager quelques conseils pour
que vous puissiez avoir des tenues ou en
tout cas des pièces indémodables que
vous allez donc garder sur du long terme
c'est beaucoup plus éthique alors voici
quelques conseils
le carreau le tartan le pied de poule
vraiment tous les motifs à base de
carreaux c'est vraiment quelque chose
que vous devez avoir impérativement dans
votre dressing si vous voulez acheter
moins mais mieux et de ce fait conserver
plus longtemps vos vêtements par exemple
ce trench en partant vous pourrez le
garder toute votre vie c'est quelque
chose qui est complètement indémodable
et c'est ça qui est intéressant en fait
et si vous voulez l'actualiser au bout
du jour il vous suffira de mettre une
ceinture de l'époque dans laquelle nous
serons dans quelques années ou en tout
cas de l'accessoiriser avec des
chaussures ou un sac et c'est comme ça
aussi que vous allez pouvoir le faire
perdurer dans le temps un motif hyper
tendance c'est certain ça date des
années 70 et encore je pense qu'il y en
avait même avant le poids c'est vraiment
un indémodable que vous devez
impérativement avoir dans votre
garde-robe si vous voulez avoir des
pièces qui ne se démotent pas le motif
fleuri c'est quelque chose qu'on qui
traverse complètement le temps que ce
soit en plus en hiver au printemps en
été vous pouvez le porter toute l'année
et ça c'est plutôt bien donc je vous
invite vraiment à miser sur des pièces
avec des carreaux des fleurs des pois ce
que je vous conseille vraiment pour
avoir une garde-robe qui va perdurer
dans le temps c'est de privilégier des
pièces plutôt simples qui ont une coupe
simple vous voyez par exemple ce
chemisier je l'ai cousu cette année mais
dans 10 ans on pourra avoir l'impression
qu'il vient seulement d'être cousu vous
voyez parce que justement il a une forme
simple il faut vraiment que vous misiez
sur des formes plutôt simples parce que
si vous prenez des vêtements qui ont des
attraits particuliers à l'instant T à
l'époque t dans laquelle vous l'avez
acheté ils vont plus vite passer de mode
et du coup ce sera beaucoup plus
compliqué pour vous de les porter
ensuite donc vraiment miser sur la forme
simple d'un vêtement et aller chercher
l'originalité et l'intemporalité sur le
motif en conclusion je vous invite
vraiment à vous tourner vers des pièces
qui ont des coûts plutôt simple et avec
des motifs intemporels comme les
carreaux le fleuri ou encore les pois
pour que vous puissiez avoir une vraie
garde-robe éthique et éco-responsable
qui dure dans le temps
[Musique]